how do you think about bitcoin when it
starts to become less volatile so
obviously everything is kind of crashing
against bitcoin because bitcoin's price
is going up at a pretty insane uh rate
compared to us dollars if bitcoin is to
eventually reach price stability in u.s
dollar terms which
may or may not happen but if that was to
occur how do you think about it then
being denominated all these other assets
yeah so i think if you look at a lot of
things there's a pretty fantastic chart
out there that i don't have on me at the
moment but it's over the last 20 years
the price of everything um
from like technology to education to
health care to consumer goods and
you know the university education and
basically everything that technology has
touched
is is way down at the price of the the
price of a tv or a semiconductor or just
an iphone think about how much an iphone
gives you over the last 10 years well
maybe the price has gone up but the
value is gone way way up so actually
technology um it's it's deflationary in
the sense that you get more for less um
and so when you when you don't have that
expanding you know
monetary unit the dollar expanding money
supply that's chasing everything that's
becoming more expensive over the last
decade or two it's because more dollars
are chasing that university education
subsidized healthcare subsidized all of
these things that are becoming way way
more expensive it's because
essentially the government or you know
just the economy in general is chasing
an increasing amount of
throwing an increasing amount of dollars
at it and so that's why you see these
things becoming exponentially more
expensive over time
i believe on a bitcoin standard on an
absolutely scarce monetary standard
global monetary standard uh things will
gradually uh decrease in in price over
time as the as the money approves value
basically as the world becomes more
productive uh your money accrues value
uh in everything else and so i think
that's what you know what the future
holds and it won't you won't see these
exponential gains that we see uh over
the last decade and i think over the
coming decade but uh you know i think
you would expect with human productivity
your purchasing power would increase one
to two to maybe five percent a year
depending uh on a bitcoin standard and i
think that's you know that's pretty
exciting
when you start to think about um how
well people understand this like what's
your take on the jack dorsey web three
tweets versus uh uh kind of the web
three pro argument if you will like what
do you think
yeah i think um i i kind of agree with
jack here in the sense that i i'm all
for the free market and i'm all for you
know people going and building things
and trying things out a hundred percent
um but i think a lot of uh the
incentives are skewed in a lot of these
if you want to call it web3
uh applications or ecosystems um whether
it's you know with and and not that you
know investing is bad in general right
you know the argument for pre-mine is
well every stock or company is pre-mined
um and that's fair but uh you know if
we're talking about a company or a
security versus an open protocol i think
it's a lot you know a little bit
different or actually a lot different
and so you know bitcoin crypto kind of
gets all lumped into one uh and i think
it's it's quite different uh we covered
it a little bit last week the
differences between say bitcoin and
ethereum uh and i'm fine i'm all for the
free market i don't want regulators to
come in and clamp down on on these
builders or engineers um at all but i
think just in terms of
say an open internet and uh you know
so-called decentralization um a lot of
it's more decentralization theater and
that's fine i think just there's quite a
difference between say bitcoin uh versus
what a lot of these other tokens
protocols um web3 applications are doing
and that's fine right
but just you know saying everything is
going to be on a blockchain or creator
economy and everyone's going to have
their own personal token um i mean it's
ambitious and so we'll see what happens
but you know i think the biggest kind of
idea in the room uh is you know what
jack thinks and that's sound money for
the world i think that's that's the big
idea here